hello everyone this is Gavin and Dan
coming to you live from inside the
Internet except it's not like not like
obviously pre-recorded yeah we're doing
a voiceover this boy so we rarely do
this but uh dan knows a lot about guns
and he wants to talk about guns well in
a little bit we're using a different
camera on this one it's the V 1610 is
the same camera we used to shoot
underwater that is incredibly slow this
is at 18,000 frames a second 18,000 you
can count it you got one two three four
cases in the air there's always like a
tiny little ember on the edge of there
yeah the rim of the case flying out I
got the gun shakes yeah it's crazy it
looks sturdy as hell then it's pretty
rattling slimmer you can even see when
we speed it up slightly like that your
watch is rattling around my wrist - oh
yeah pretty efficient machine of every
movement moving is for a purpose
yeah mine pin now is impacting on the
primer of the of the round that fires
the bullet out and then the empty case
gets ejected so it's been pulled
backwards here using the force of the
gas to pull the working part so there's
nothing actually pulling that back its
genetic force of the bullet going out
that's eject the gas is yeah they're
being created and then the next round
gets loaded in when the spring on the
other side asserts itself extracting the
next round from them I see the next
round go up yes just there it gets
loaded into the chamber and then the
firing pin again impinges on the primer
of the of the round okay that ignites
the inside the round and that causes the
gas to force the bullet out the end of
the barrel and the case out of the rear
this is my favorite part
wide-eyed you are there your life whoa
looks like you see the Yeti
yeah I went back quite a way yeah you
did crap yourself on the first shot
there was you literally took a step back
you let a little bit of seppuku came out
all right so yeah now's the part down
where I really show you how it's done my
first time ever firing an assault rifle
especially fully automatic for this I'd
only have a fire a pistol and a shotgun
see my reaction time is I haven't
blinked yet the rounds already been
fired by this point so it's the round
has already probably gone through oh now
that exited the target rifle is pushing
back because you didn't have it fully in
your shoulder what I did in my shoulder
but my lean was wrong I was leaning
about there there goes the eye oh so
I've already killed someone and I've
just now blinking yeah he's blinking
still firing still firing obviously I'm
not gonna let off the trigger yeah sure
yeah baby close your eyes just fire oh
nice little vent of gas there yeah speed
up I can see the amount that I control
of that I was just told not to let go of
the trigger so the rest of it was oh you
did a good job with that so now I'm
thinking right let's try get his gun
back pointed towards the ground while
I'm trying to walk forwards again cuz on
the other camera probably completely
yeah now the gun is gonna have focus but
you can see some pretty sharp shots to
the cases coming out pretty cool
it's weird after you get to the point
where you know what's going on and you
don't blink me every single shot is like
but you just don't blink is we get
punished that you're used to what's
going on
well this thing called erm keyhole where
when you find an automatic your first
shot goes on target the next one's
slightly further up then slightly
further out and then it comes back round
and down again when you get it back in
the control when you realize what's
happening so obviously you've got like a
huge keyhole it's ridiculous just
hurling chunks of metal and you're not
even really aim
you want to be it's just like your
body's your body's not good enough to
fire this gun not blink the foot the
first round is always the most
difficulties and then they after that
you've got get usable all right well
thanks for watching our gun video also
thanks to Destin from smarter every day
for setting that shoe up that was well
worth hanging out with destiny Alabama -
you have a lot of fun doing it as well
yeah if you like guns stuff be sure to
check out his channel also check out the
video we did with underwater pistols
follow us both on twitter my twitter
name is Gavin free also happens to be my
real name what about you Daniel - Daniel
Gruchy again happens to be my real not
Gruchy not actually not going she not
brauch no none of those grew she
technically
[Laughter]
[Music]